mothers grieving for their newborn
babies who died in the neonatal ward of
the public hospital
i'm heartbroken i'm a parent in mourning
and i cannot understand why god took my
newborn child away this way dozens of
premature babies were left unattended
under uv lights when a suspected short
circuit started the fire the smell of
smoke woke retired police officer el
hajj mansurimbup who lives
i
nearby
the smell of human flesh of babies
burning i think it's too gruesome the
state is responsible for this because
the state is responsible for the safety
especially public buildings so the
responsibility lies within the state
the government announced three days of
national mourning and an investigation
to fix responsibility
security forces and police have been
deployed around this hospital that has
been cordoned off and also to contain
the crowd the government says
this was an unfortunate incident but
people here see gross negligence they
say some of them that we've spoken to
that they tried to break inside the ward
but the fire extinguishers were not
working there was no sprinklers and
there was no alarm bells
last year several newborns were killed
in similar circumstances in another
maternity ward fire last week a newborn
declared dead was found alive in a
morgue and another national crime
protest were provoked when a pregnant
mother died after nurses and doctors
were accused of failing to assist her
we want to remind the government of
their responsibility to ensure that all
citizens especially women and children
are given the care they deserve and we
invite citizens to denounce the
injustice and negligence that exists in
our hospitals
government critics say funds meant to go
to hospitals are going into the pockets
of officials with not enough nurses and
too many seemingly preventable deaths
senegalese people are trying to make
sense of this latest tragedy in what
appears to be a broken health system
nicholas hawk al jazeera 201.